so I'm curious pro-choicers when I'm
assuming you guys think life begins a
conception yeah okay
um pro-choicers when do you guys think
Life Begins how many weeks months what
is it what do you guys think should
abortion be legal up to birth three
weeks a month like what's your starting
here and then
go ahead go ahead sorry yeah when should
abortion be legalized
um well to be fair
the laws at the moment isn't it like 12
weeks or something
24.
it's six months six months okay I don't
agree with that but I'm sure that at
some point was it 12 weeks I don't know
where I got that from but I'm sure
that's something
yeah it's not 12 weeks is is what you
can get the pill up to is it the pill
and then after that you can get the pill
for longer beyond that all right
but it becomes more likely that you'll
get a surgical the later on that you're
getting it yeah yeah well they're
literally taking the mick with it right
now they've
um they're talking about putting it up
to like two months off or a month off
there was there was that's too much
that's a murder to me yeah that's too
much yeah I wasn't aware of that because
I don't know the stats some children
have survived at less than six months at
like five and a half yeah
up to three months and then after that
if you don't want it just give it to
adoption there's lots of people that
can't have kids after that just give
birth give it to us yeah I mean at six
months you're almost all the way there
you know what I mean when you're 12
weeks isn't that when you have like your
first scan like when I had my son I have
a nine-year-old so when I had my son you
have your first gun when you're 12 weeks
and then you have another one when
you're 25 weeks and that's when you find
out the sex
um I would say in my world
depending on people's circumstances
everyone's different but when they have
a if they if they do get pregnant then
um I would say up to maybe just before
12 weeks or up to 12 weeks because there
must be a reason why you have your first
scan that 12 weeks I'm not sure exactly
the scientific yeah stuff behind it but
there must be a reason why you don't see
anything like about a heartbeat like if
I go if there was complications or at
one point I was like six weeks and I
started spotting I spottings when you
start seeing blood when you're pregnant
um then you would go and get an exam but
when you go to get that exam because
it's an early pregnancy scam you can't
even go and get a scan on your belly
they actually put like this special
camera inside you because it's too small
to see anything so if your child is if
child embryo what everyone has their
different tones but when um fetus is
that small I would I would say in my
head it would sit right with me I have a
nephew that was premature and he was
born at six months old and my nephew was
Tiny he weighed about
the same
weight as a bag of sugar literally he
was Tiny like that so he was like so he
was like so you you would agree that the
six months at least yeah like six months
is too much for me because when my
nephew was born he was a baby like he
was in an incubator so I have a question
for a woman that aborts a kid after six
months should she face jail time
um no that see that's touchy obviously
certain people go through certain
traumatic experiences which would make
them maybe angry in in that sense but I
don't think a woman should go to jail
for having whatever [__] what if
what if um the mom has the kid and then
the Dad throws it off of a bridge should
he go to jail
if the woman has the kid at six months
old and then the Dad throws it off the
bridge should he go to jail well of
course that's murder
wouldn't it be the same thing though no
because when it's still it's still
inside of the woman
it hasn't it's still inside of the woman
it's a part of the woman so the woman
can still use the whole my body my
choice when she's physically giving
birth that is a human entity in its own
yeah Breathing by itself doing
everything by itself so then so then
that's going to go off of location then
shouldn't you just Legalize It Up to
nine months no like the day before she
gives birth she says no because I'm in
it I hear what you're saying however I
think that because due to the
development and how a baby is developed
I think it's more Humane to do it when
the the fetus or whatever the
terminology is hasn't fully developed
into a child yeah I still am pro-choice
I'm saying it's like there needs to be a
certain stop to it I'm I'm for it for
three months and maybe four out of push
my only question is I'm just curious why
there would not if you don't if you
think it should be illegal at six right
which I think we would agree on right
six months is too far along yeah I'm
just curious should not make that
decision it just seems like whenever
there's a consequence for women like we
always want to bail women out no no no
so it's like when when there would be a
legal consequence then we're like oh no
that's too far no no I watched something
yesterday on on Prime and it was about
um a woman who basically
um was uh obsessed with this guy so much
to the point where I'm pretty sure I
haven't finished the series yet but I'm
pretty sure she commits suicide in order
to frame him now I know there's some
women that do deserve to be reprimanded
for their actions however being pregnant
and having that you don't know the
reason how someone's got pregnant you
don't know their finances even even it
could be rape as well even in the
example with the guy you don't know the
reason why he wanted to throw the kid
off the bridge yeah that's got to be
some type of mental problem right but
I'm correct but I'm saying we all have
reasons we commit crimes but if that was
a crime like why would she not have a
punishment yeah some people commit
crimes because of money some people
commit crimes because of Revenge some
people commit crimes for madness we
don't know however I think abortion is
is not necessarily a crime it can't be
compared to physically throwing a human
being off of a well it could be if it
was illegal like it is a crime after
there's a girl that's going to jail
right now
um overtaking the abortion pills too
late so it is a crime sorry go ahead
um well you guys can interject too if
you have anything go ahead I was um
I was gonna say like the
The Madness of
you know about rapists right yes you
know about they have actual rights
over
so grapists grape someone
they get pregnant
they the rapist and The Grapist family
have rights over the child that they've
just created through grape
can we ever be seeing group someone say
I'm sorry it's not funny uh is that true
if he's it's true he's convicted he's
convicted and if you look into it there
is a family that ended up fighting for
custody of their son who raped this
young girl
over the the child and they got
visitation rights and they got like
excuse me like you have they imagine
just imagine how traumatized you would
be anyway
and then you have to do you have to did
he go to jail for it
that stuff yeah that one that I read he
got convicted okay so his his mum I'm
just surprised his mom or his mom was
like the one that said I want to be in
the child's life and they said no as you
would
and she won and she was allowed to see
the baby now it's like but you've heard
it vice versa where a female teacher
well grape so so tell me about it you
can put the kid on child support and she
yeah
and the amount of the amount of
disgusting disgusting
families right females
that do it
and they get nothing because they're a
girl because it's a woman and it's like
I don't know yeah it's
in in a in a in a chronographic way it's
like oh my head like my old teacher my
older teacher fancies me when it's a
younger boy and an older woman right but
if you switch it and it there's Opera
everyone's like that's gonna stand now
my gosh like get him arrested these
women are going into prison and then
getting sent money daily from these
weird old guys yeah that are like oh I
wish that you as my teacher and sending
them money and they're now like
glorified like it's like let me tell us
did the Ted Bundy
oh yeah I know I know they do yeah I
know that it's it's a problem because
it's but the grapest thing that's
another reason why I think they should
that's why that's one pushing me to one
side it's like if you want to keep that
child and and it's a child of grape cool
that's your book that shouldn't have
access to it exactly she has to she has
to then see this rapist for the rest of
her life right yeah yeah it does sound
though that oh that sounds really
traumatic I definitely agree with that
but it does send the solution to that
though is a legal issue related to
parental rights and the solution is not
abortion in that situation
what would it be well it would it it
it's not really abortion until I'm
saying my point is that could be a
problem that
like I didn't have access
so I wasn't able to get an abortion and
now I'm having to have this child with a
Grapist
I'm sure yeah I know I understand that
would be a really difficult situation to
be in
um but again it sounds well firstly it
does sound like a better solution to
tackle that is obviously reducing rape
first of all I accept that that will
never be zero percent
um but even with the with the problem
that you're raising again this sounds
like a a problem that we need to tackle
with kind of rapist rights
um rather than than say abortion is a
solution to that and you know in that
situation I don't think it's a solution
at all right but um and my point is just
that a lot of these girls that talk
about it have said they've not had
access as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible